their first footsteps on safe soil like
so many others Sonata Anza new and their
family fled the Army in Myanmar through
the forest across the border hanging on
to little more than their lives they
have to make a new home here now in
Bangladesh their old one was destroyed
looking back across the border they can
see the smoke from burning row hinge of
villages who are the military entered
our village they went from house to
house and burn everything down they
looted a village and shot at the people
who were trying to run away we have no
choice but to flee at the moment their
most important task is to find a place
to stay but the refugee camps in the
area are bursting at the seams
over 400,000 row Hendra have poured into
Bangladesh in the last few weeks alone
when I was last here in December some
nine months ago none of these Hut's that
you see behind me were in place they
just literally sprung up within the last
few weeks and now every inch of ground
is covered with these makeshift shelters
and it's not only like that here this
stretches for miles in every direction
and it's absolutely overwhelming to see
the massive influx of people that has
happened here and it's even worse to see
the living conditions that they're in
those who haven't been able to find a
place in one of the camps yet are the
most vulnerable they have no access to
clean water or toilets it's especially
bad for the many many small children
this woman gave birth to a baby girl
while on the run the infant is only 18
days old and won't eat her mother says
she's vomiting and
diarrhea Sindelar nada I'm so worried
about her I already lost four of my
children when our village was attacked
perfectly healthy kids if I lose this
one too I don't know what greater pain
that could be yeah
the people here are completely dependent
on the uncoordinated aid deliveries that
come in and medical care is grossly
insufficient so not and her family
reached the camp's the finding space
here is not an easy task
the gnats father asks around but most
spots are already taken and in many
cases they would have to pay I can't
find anything I don't know what we'll do
they have no choice but to go back and
join those outside the camps for now but
with thousands of new refugees arriving
every day finding shelter won't become
any easier